B
T FRONHIFRDE
OUSE OFFIA W
CONCERN OVER
CLFI FOUNDT
TRNTLI CNN HINDCLOSED DOORSA DI
CONCERN IS LIK FROM
MENTS DERAL JUDGE
ABOUT WHAT THE DEPARTMEN S THAAI
TES GATING
THE WORDS RI IN THATDOCUMENT UN
RELATED  A OF, Y
FEE THIS LINE, WILLFUL RETTI
THAT IS POLAUA
IT IS LANGUAGE THAPENS THE
TRUMP HIMSEA JECT
AND THE DEVELOEN FROM
HOUSE TONIGHT COME AS
THERE ARE DEVELOPMEN UY 6TH ANDO
JOHN CARE GOING BOUT FMEPRIDPOYT
CARL ASKING  PEN
TSHIHA
>>S ID TESTIFYING.
HIS COUNSU THINK WE'LL SEHIREO
KNT OF THE
DAY. WHAT ABOUT TRUMP, BEFYO U?
>> I DON'T WANT AKANUNT THAT TH
MORNING.
STVET >> WELL, WE'RE GOING TO SP
WITH ANOTHER MR OF THE
TEE,O FEW MOMENTS.
>>> THE FULTON COUNTY DISTRICT A
Y OFTASPERGER AFTER THE 2020
EC TR WH
SANT, GRAES
DID NOT LIVEA.THE SENATOFR
CARO.HE WAS AERUM SERAEN
HE UNDERSTOOD HIS CALLS FROM
.
Y D  WT HE TOOH A OW MANBALLOTSO
S LL FSAID T
GEORGIA.
THAT CALL NOE HE
THAT TRUMP MADE TO EN A I
JUST WAND 11,780OT
>> KAITLAN COLLINS BEGINOUONIGH
HO
ANE NEOU
WHAT MORE ARE YOUR SOURCES U?
W
BASICALLY ANYTHING ISON, PUICEL
THERE IS A PRETTGH LEVF N ABOULT
MAR-A-LAANPO
THAT TRET T RISK BE
IN A SECURED FACILITY AS THEENT
FROM MAR- KNOW
SPECIFICALLY WHAT THE DOCUMENTS
WERE.
YOU SAW THAT INVENTORY LIST THMA
JUDGE UNSEALED IT, THAT DISTAT,
SECURE GERTIS
PEOPLE HERE WHO WORK AWHITE HOUR
AN E WATCH TO
T THISNF
THEY ARE CONCERNED, WHAT WARAR
POTENTIALLY PUT THD
UR U.S.
INTELLIGENCE COMMITTEE PS AT
THEY'RE NOT SUHOSE HANDS IS WAS
MATIONITAS A
SE
Y WEREO NCERNED ABOUT .
THEY HAVE GREAT CONCERNS ABOUT
WE KNOC
ES FOR THE
INTELLIGENCE COMMUNITY HAVE
SPOKEN TO THE IC
S,T'SOMETHING WEE G FROM THELIG
HEY ARE
ER THENT
T
FTER TH  GO.
MAR-A-,  GOT T PPE
D D E RECEIPT.H
ERONOUS ENTRY,
INENT OF
OWOO T
WHAT ARE YOU LEARNINACTUALLY ONE
HE WHITE
HOUSE HAS IS, YOU KNOW, DOESTHI
FON WAS.S TAY  TALK OUT A NOTE I
IT HAS RAISED EYEBROWS ABOUT ATO
THAT'S THEIR CONCEIS
PUT IN SOURCES AND
METH RISK, ANDMATIOND LEADERS.E
MAR-A-LAGO.
KAITLACO THA Y
TE HOUSE
>>> LET'S GO TO RYAN GOODMAN,
PENCE.
THERE STILL WORKING IN THE
WHIT WT N  T
DOR ESAT ABOUT
>> WELL,INCREDIB
IT RIGHT NOWIGURE OUWHCTLY
ADVERSARIES, THE  AND WHO SAW
AMOUNT OF FOREIGNERS THAT GO ON
ERTY, AND SO'DJUST BE CONCER WAN
WHETHER AN OUR DEFENSE
S ON THE
ACROSSL MUO LDS A NCOUT OUR HO
ND NAT
AS A WHOLE, WOUL CONCERNISRYAN,
BE CETSTIFIED IN THE
CONCNS
F HAVE I
COME OUTUBHE WG IN.
RIGHT?AVE SO STEADFASTLY
RE SIG                    LE, OT
IN
RAID UNTIL IENED, ME
SHOULD OFFICIAN BE TALKING
> IN A NO T
A MAJOR CONCERN,
SUPPOSED HAVINCONVERSATIONS WIT
CRIMINAL INVESTIGATION.
WHAT DO THEY
THAT THE PEOPLE AT THEHEST  W T.
>> AT ALL, RIGHTHE ANSWER FROM C
RIT , HE
STOU O
ABOUT THE FRENCH
PRESIDENT,
ST SPIFOULD
UND IN THE DOCUMENTS
THAT THE FIDENT KEPT TH HIM.
HO
>> TRUMP WAS NES A
MO BEHONEST WIT S A TEE RELATI
ALG STLY WHEN I
LIAT MAKLDS
VIND KNOWN TO BEAND ANY
IO THAT, HE WOULD
PROBABLYANG ON TO.
WE DON'T KNOSIATION  OF
OR MEETTE
HEAS O I
MEAN, YOKNL ARAT.
WE HAVE NOA.
DONALD TRUMP, HE IS A MAO
S GRUDGES AN
FORGET.
, WONDERHYHE TO PRESERVE TT, IEH
RN
IT HURTS PARTNERIPE'S INTELLIGEG
ETWEEN ORTNERS, AND I'SUOUOW, IF
BE SITTING T
IO I
>> ABSOLUTELESOWCOO PROVIDABTRP
EF NOTENT OFTOP TRUMP ALLIES HE
CL AT
MAR-A-LAGO.
HERE'S THE LS FORMER L
>> THEY WANT TNG TAKENCLASSIFIED
REALLY, IF YOUK AT THE
ESE T,S NOT RELYT TAKING THETS,S
ABOUT DESTNGIDING
THEM OR GIVING THEM HE >>
>> IT'S NOABPUTTINPLACE
THAT'S RGHS N IN THE FRE?
IT'RERDINAR
EXCHANGE
HENG TO Y ENTATI
ENTS OF THE ESPIONAGT.NOTE
THAT WAS REVEALED YESTERDAY R
E WORDS
ARE THAT THEY'GA
P FOR THE WIL RETENTION NAL DEI
TO KEEP
NATIONAL DEFENON. T T TACKINIT